and tickets go on sale in just a few
hours now for life is beautiful it is
happening this year
you'll remember john it was canceled
last year like everything else because
of cobid of course it is a big event for
downtown las vegas life is beautiful but
what does the future hold for
las vegas entertainment more broadly
hector mejia as you see
is live in downtown las vegas with
details on that hector good morning to
you
hilary good morning and the industry is
optimistic now that more people are
getting vaccinated
10 o'clock this morning is when the
tickets go on sale for life is beautiful
and every time it comes into town they
set up these beautiful murals this looks
like a cat
a talented cat playing the trumpet and
these murals have revitalized downtown
it's been almost a year and a half since
people packed the streets here in
downtown for a festival
and life is beautiful coming back in
september is a welcoming sign for local
entertainers
they tell us it means las vegas is
poised to bring back live
entertainment we'll see some changes
though possibly no more
audience participation for some
productions
since the governor began to pull back
showroom capacity limits
we've seen some shows back on stage
including
absinthe pif the magic dragon taped face
and carrot top
the industry is adapting as it slowly
reopens
hearing a lot of just sentiment from
visitors who'd come into town
it's you know i want to go to vegas but
it just doesn't feel the same
the faster we get entertainment up and
running i think we'll start filling in
the voids that
the tourists the travelers the visitors
coming in here feel like they're missing
[Music]
some in the industry believe visitors
will get more reassurance that travel is
safe and people can gather with
protocols in place
as coronavirus vaccinations ramp up
that's when we might see capacity
restrictions ease up
and bigger shows return to large venues
and remember of
edc well that's still on track to happen
this year in may officials tell us
they're working with
local officials to make sure those
states stay in place we hope they do
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
yeah absolutely hope they do hector
thank you
and edc john is sold out already
the latest on the website yeah so